you're ready to speak wherever you want
to speak hello i'm
ewan jones i'm a youtuber i come to here
to
speaker's corner and do youtube videos
and i made one earlier this year
it was in march 2018 and in the video
there was um it was basically 120
decibels movement which is a group of
european women who come you know they
they uh basically go across
the continent and they do talks about
migrant rapes against indigenous
european women
and so they came here to speaker's
corner to do a talk
and anti-far the radical left-wing
terrorist group they came to speaker's
corner that day
and i recorded footage of uh the events
that unfolded
and so i recorded footage of
basically being anti-social to everyone
here
being wrongly hated by everyone at
speaker's corner
people telling them to piss off people
telling them they were idiots
they were putting on their face masks
they were putting on their balaclavas
they were
turning the whole scene into one of
degeneracy and disorder
and then 120 decibels
they turned up and anti-far charged for
them
and had to be separated by a line of
police officers
and then that was over there um at that
entrance and then
120 decibels went round to a further
entrance
auntie far charged the men again had to
be stopped by a line of police officers
and 120 decibels did their talk
in the corner it was a young woman from
germany
freyja who was talking about migrant
rapes and how this had
affected her in her own life and we had
auntie far
at the police line hurling abuse at them
uh screaming you don't know what you're
doing and all of these other
disgusting intimidating tactics they
were separated from them by the police
and then we saw anti-fart leave after
that so
i i showed that and i showed freya's
speech in the video
i uploaded it to youtube it was doing
really well
um it got to about 10 000 hits and then
like in a day it had like a 5 000 more
and then youtube immediately banned the
video
um they didn't fully ban it for hate
speech but they
put ridiculous restrictions on it so it
couldn't be shown
in the uk or in another 30 or so
countries
this included countries i'd never heard
of before
such as reunion island and so on
and um they said uh basically even
though it doesn't fully fit the criteria
for hate speech
we basically think it is that so we're
going to impose massive restrictions on
it
and i was just thinking afterwards all
i've done is shown
anti-far being a bunch of absolutes and
utter
morons being you know a bunch of
reprehensible idiots violent towards
women yeah exactly violence towards
women
um and so why is it that youtube are
trying to shut this down why don't they
want this to be shown to
the world why is it that you know as
steve
bannon uh as he did his talk here in the
uk he was interviewed by
piers morgan and suzanne reid uh you
know when trump did his state visit
and he said that the mainstream media
they
always let anti-far off even though this
organization are violent they're against
free speech
and yeah they uh yeah they attack women
they do all sorts of
disgusting horrible activities and yet
they're always given a by
by the police by the mainstream media by
all of the institutions that control our
society
and i've certainly had experience of
this in the fact that this particular
video
of mine was just massive restrictions
were put on it
and all it showed was anti-fog being a
bunch of
[__] [__] so sorry can i use
that last bit
oh
being a bunch of horrible disgusting
reprehensible people
so why is that good question thank you
so much for your time thank you